uh good
afternoon those of you who are joining
us for om the afternoon session I want
to um welcome you and say we're late in
getting started because we had such a
productive morning and such a great
outpouring of ideas uh in in in multiple
papers the reason I'm stalling
dramatically or obviously is because we
can't find professor khoff
and you know I've learned that it's
harder to organize Germans than any
other National
Group um however we're going to start um
uh and I will hope that he will
appear um uh if not um well The Show
Must Go On he is in New Haven we've seen
him um as recently
as recently as a few hours ago um so
tonight the topic today this afternoon
uh the first of the two panels This
Afternoon the topic for it is building
the capitol city missed
opportunities um and it provides our
three panelists we hope three Hans Koff
Peter Eiserman and Jorgen mayaha the
opportunity to consider unfulfilled
promises in Berlin's recent
architectural
development each of these Architects has
direct experience of Berlin contributing
to the discussion of what might have
been and um what should have been and
what might have
been in what Pro Professor Forester
described in his Thursday evening
keynote as a tentative
Capital Professor Hans Koff studied
architecture at the University of Kalua
with Egon Ironman as well as at the
Vienna University of Technology in
Austria Professor Koff taught at Cornell
University as an assistant to Oswald
Matias ERS ERS is one of the key links
it would appear um it it is certainly
the case in discussing recent and
contemporary issues in Berlin and he and
after assisting ERS um Professor Koff
later uh taught at the Technical
University of Berlin since 1990 he's
been professor of architecture at the AA
in
zurk um and in 1984 with Helga Timmerman
he embarked upon Private Practice
realizing some of Eur Germany's most
widely discussed and prominent buildings
he is now in the
auditorium I am feeling much
better um with Tim he dear embarked upon
pra Private Practice realizing some of
Germany's most widely discussed and
prominent buildings at key burin
locations such as unane Linden and
friedi straa as well as the skyscraper
at pot stommer plots um uh and the
conversion of the fmer former Berliner
Reich spun to you new use and new
purpose as the foreign Office of the New
Berlin Republic professor koff's
quintessentially refined architecture
stands apart from the Contemporary scene
because of its attention to detail and
its respect for the traditions of German
architecture and urbanism especially
those of the shamefully neglected
expressionist work of the inter War
years Peter Eiserman is Charles GUI
professor in practice here at Yale
Professor Eiserman is an internationally
recognized architect and educator whose
work includes two significant buildings
in Berlin the house at Checkpoint
Charlie which you heard about from
Professor Forester the other night and a
highly acclaimed memoral to the murdered
Jews of Europe though unrealized as
Professor forer made clear in his
lecture Professor eisman's Max Reinhardt
tower has had a tremendous impact on
contemporary production Professor isman
holds the Bachelor of architecture
degree from Cornell the master of
science in architecture from Columbia
and the ma in and PhD degrees from
Cambridge University prior to
establishing a full-time architectural
practice in 1980 Mr Eisman worked as an
independent architect educator and
theorist in 1967 he founded the
institute for architecture and urban
studies um an international think tank
for architecture in New York um where he
served as director until 1982 and where
I believe I'm correct in saying REM
kulas spent a year uh during which time
he worked feverishly on his book
Delirious New York Jurgen mayaha is a
leader of the new generation of German
Architects founder in 1996 and principal
of the berlin-based cross-disciplinary
studio that bears his name Professor
myaha uh uh studied architecture at
stutgart University from which he
graduated in
1992 he received the master of
architecture in 1994 from Princeton
University his work has been published
at and exhibited worldwide as part of a
um numerous collections including those
of the Museum of Modern Art in New York
and the SF Moma Jurgen maaha has taught
in the US at Princeton Harvard and
Columbia and in Berlin at the University
of the Arts and the k h um as well um
serving as respondent to this afternoon
session is Ram kulas who joins us
through the magic of the internet by way
of Doha where it's in the middle of the
night so these talks better be Lively so
we can keep our moderator attentive and
awake he's on the screen right now REM
cool house first came to public and
critical attention with Omar om the
office of Metropolitan architecture uh
um the office he founded in
1975 together with Architects Ilia zenis
Zoe zenis and mine vendor and they
founded that in London while many
consider New York in in in a way to be
the foundation stone for the
OM edifice um given the importance of
the book Delirious New York to
establishing um the coolhouse position
the architectural historian Fritz Norm
has pointed out that om's place of
origin was not New York but Berlin from
where the path led to um as noriah Riley
puts it quote less spectacular but
similar
Del Delirious
um created a journey that was less
spectacular but similarly Delirious
locating Berlin um uh as the centerpiece
or the foundation stone of the OM
practice um and the ideas that Li behind
it um is particularly appropriate for
our uh proceedings today among om's most
many notable and recognized projects I
want to draw your attention to but one
the Dutch Embassy in Berlin which won
the architectur price in Berlin in 2003
and um the Mis vandero award for
European architecture in 2005 REM we
welcome you from Yale um and we'll hear
more from you later H but now I turn the
platform over to Professor
Koff
thanks for your patience hello
REM
um I
think
the city doesn't have to be
invented
again and
uh because the concept of the city has
proven in history history to be flexible
Without
Limits and uh secondly I believe the
city is made up of houses houses in the
German sense uh it's not just
residential but it's units of
buildings I think you have to look
closely what is there when you're
working in a city that's what I learned
among other things from Matias unas and
you need a morphological capacity to
translate it into a new
project above all you need a sense for
where people of different taste wealth
origin and so on feel at home because
that is what the city is all about and
finally people want to be proud of their
city and want to hand it over to Future
Generations
um and in order to accomplish that that
it doesn't have to be just
beautiful but also
durable this
principle not just
functions in Europe it functions in
America and it uh functions also again
in the slums of South America and uh
Asia the principle is
basically private land
ownership
parcelation public private space
architectural treatment which is rooted
in the citizens self Rec recognition of
their Heritage and of their future
aspirations the concept of social
housing as it has been practiced in East
and West Germany is destructive to this
idea of the city that's why during the
ebbi years it had been transformed and
uh
translated closer to Urban
principles
now
I have a
quick view of this
experience
since I've been working in Berlin poama
plots we have seen this picture
before from the venders
film where is the poama
plat and there
were for me and others of my generation
in West
Berlin
um very strong impacts of those images
of poama plots in our early work uh that
was the time when the periphery was
somehow an ideal of the future
city and we have seen a lot of uh
destruction photos
pictures um but there were in the late
60s early 70s there were artists coming
up with images like this one a painting
by
herik who sudden ly uh gave you an idea
that this is not just War
destruction uh what you are living in in
such an area at P Platz uh it it gives
you a sense
of uh width a sense of looking to the
Horizon and uh he describes moments of
uh uh Beauty uh looking at
plots um when the Sun goes down and uh
so in that time you felt that uh uh
these these images have an
incredible uh uh
provocation of going on and uh turning
it into a positive uh
experience um um we also have seen some
of these first projects here again in
the picture we have not seen yet um the
uh Collective plan under Sheron with the
this
incredible um building from leika plots
all the way to the east which was uh
really um inter interpreted as a
building here the city before for the
destruction in red uh the uh plan by
spare and uh uh the perspective of the
collective
plan um you you see the Octagon on the
left hand side that is liiga plats and
there's a gigantic structure going all
over uh to the east to
ksb and um the Smithson with the the two
levels of car traffic and pedestrian
traffic um the configuration of lipika
plots has disappeared like
others
leier
faint yeah yeah okay thanks a faint
uh
rest of the the Octagon is still
visible and uh our
first
um contribution to the question how are
you going to be going are you going
about after the wall has gone uh with
this area this was in 91 or
'92 I believe uh we started working
working with a computer this is uh what
you were able to do at that time the
white line you see back there uh is the
Horizon it was incredibly difficult at
that time to fill up that Gap to the
Horizon and the and the um the idea of
course as you see here was completing uh
the block structure along liikaa
completing the configur ation of the
Octagon you have seen several pictures
uh these days with the Octagon as a
street configuration in this desert uh
along the wall so rebuilding that space
uh with the
volume um it had originally but then we
interpreted the
um the the former border where the wall
has been which at the same time was the
Border uh of uh Berlin before the city
went uh uh to the West with an extrusion
we accepted that border and said in that
green there is a cluster of high-rise uh
buildings and Alexander Platz on the
other end of
leika uh a similar project with the
only and that was a competition much
later um with the um main idea keeping
the buildings by Peta
baren uh also keeping more or less uh
that edge of the uh department store and
uh defining the square the first time in
history as a real Square not just as a a
traffic
intersection um in a scale where people
would uh want uh to be it's still would
be still a large square with the blocks
in the normal height and behind in a
second row these
highrises the
perspective
from inside the
square and U going back to that uh
time um when we started our practice in
West Berlin that was right after uh the
archipelago
project and you have seen some of these
volumes of these BR vano a firewall
buildings we were entirely intrigued by
these uh volumes
completely uh closed heavy uh solids
without Windows because it's uh they
were previously integrated into the
block system the facade is on the other
side the facade didn't interest us at
all but we related this and Fritz no
Fritz noer was mentioned and he uh at
that time worked on Jil fried Jil and he
Jil did this uh drawing this perspective
with these volumes in the landscape this
was was our
uh imagination to start with thinking
about the future of uh
Berlin and uh of course that was close
to
shinkles um experience in England where
he spoke about those uh
volumes uh um in in a in a certain in a
in a certain way of Fascination and
despair uh at the same time look at
these uh gigantic volumes without any
architecture but you feel that he was
very
enthusiastic uh about this scale and the
solidity one of the early projects after
89 we built in leik actually it was a
this the structure was already there uh
it was supposed to be an exhibition
building uh on this uh Fair site in leik
which we slightly transformed and uh put
a facade on it on it the first time
with this um
tectonic
relief of course in
stone and why Stone our IBA buildings uh
used brick and sto brick in order to go
with a construction into the ground
because with sto at that time that sto
meant insulation as you see it here and
uh on top of it plaster uh this
construction would not go into the
ground so you would need uh some metal
or something there and for us if you
look at the picture of Jil the volume
has to uh uh uh project out of the
ground be part of the earth rather than
floating over it so you needed some
other material you needed brick or you
needed Stone and uh Stone was uh
constructed in this way at that time
very cheap very very poor uh um so uh we
had to invent something else this type
of construction was taking the volume of
the building putting a square GD on it
and screwing the stone pieces uh to the
wall so um what we did uh we took these
stone slabs of three or four CM
thickness and superimposed them uh in
rectangles of course horizontally
vertically and of course you get a beam
and you get a pilaster and you are with
Alberti and in the end you are able to
make a
column this was one of the first
projects done in in this fashion
Fred um I had a long discussion with
hman about this was is missing here is a
building which was preserved but not
because it was under historic
preservation because stman said this
block is uh par in is um cut into
Parcels uh the principle of parcelation
and we want to keep it here in the
middle of the city that's why we want to
have uh uh we we want to keep this
building uh our client H was uh getting
uh
uh Furious but we had to keep the
building in the end we had to tear it
down but rebuild it again uh the same
way it was before here this uh principle
I was talking about the block with the
streets uh individual Lots private lots
and uh the
architecture um and uh when you throw a
bomb into such an area you get very
beautiful uh brand vend facades uh in
that in the corner especially by because
they are not rectangular
anymore so uh here the constructed old
building we found in that facade cast
iron columns which we integrated again
and U
um this was the first time we had the
experience of the traditional uh
architecture of the 19th century how
that relates uh to this relief of the uh
tectonic facade
and this is what you learn uh from New
York um and you have seen
the these buildings have uh different
heights it goes up and down there was a
long discussion withman about the
so-called TR in Berlin I think the TR is
not that much important uh because you
see it here important is how the
buildings
uh perform on the ground level along the
along the street uh ground level first
floor and then as they go higher than
normal in in the silhouette of the
city and uh these these streets in New
York and Chicago uh they started from
very
low uh buildings or rather low buildings
here five stories uh sometimes you you
see even three-story buildings next to a
skyscraper it works perfectly well it
has to work on uh the street
level um recently we finished a project
like that it was a large lot um in
Cologne um uh we won this competition
with kind of artificial parcellation we
cut the program into five buildings uh
we had to uh refurbish this existing
building with the same principle we just
went uh step further here it's not just
slaps anymore the relief uh is a little
bit more uh um complex and uh of
course um you can do this then with the
not just with the super imposition but
you make profiles and as soon as you
have the curved profile the rounded
profile also here um the volume is tight
together even more more than just by the
superimposition of the of the slab and
uh this is what of course what you what
you uh find so uh fast inting with
buildings from the Renaissance on until
the early 20th century here the
street and uh the base and uh it's
important in order to take a building
seriously that it has a base and the
base goes into the ground there doesn't
have to be a joint
here and of that kind is this view at
the pot plats this is our building for
the delbr bankk there our building for
mercedesbenz uh next to a building by
Kristoff
Satler a very
short uh portion of a
street where before was a desert it's
possible to build on on uh this flat
land where there is nothing it's
possible today to build a street uh uh
this is what this picture to to me
proves this is the uh location of this
uh
building this the little street is this
it doesn't go further here that is
disappointing but here you have this
idea of a city made up of
highrises um yeah
um this building has a strange
configuration especially how the uh
Tower and the block are shifted uh above
each other it's because underneath the
building is the
railway uh track and the tower had to be
um on had to be uh parallel uh to the
railroad track built across the railroad
track it was not possible to have an
alternative uh um
Foundation uh but at the same time the
block was given by the urban
plan so this is why block and Tower slab
are in a strange configuration but uh
for us that was exciting of course
because we we we liked to um uh work SC
sculpturally with the volume but not
intentionally making an interesting
figure uh it it's it's sort of
appeared uh from
inside and in order to make this
building which is not that high it's 90
M or so um to make it more slim we made
this little uh
step in the front which gives the
building a vertical
thrust the entrance here again a nice
profile around the
entry and of course without the
experience of the American highrises
this would not be possible either this
would be
possible uh
and people who worked there and people
who rented these spaces they recognized
it because it's it's full with u lawyers
firms uh uh who work internationally who
can pay this rent uh and it's the same
with uh the Mercedes tower on the other
side and uh here I mentioned this
triangular piece um of a of a
triangular uh block
this this these sculptures no facades
that was that was initially what we are
interested in and U I want to clarify
this again with one other example our
project at the kesm island uh in
Amsterdam and the Dutch experience at
that time was also very uh influential
uh for for us um this project was very
successful and was copied 100 times
everybody thought yeah this is a a new
kind of uh
expressionism we had nothing like that
in our mind uh what happened was this we
took a block that was given to us by the
urban plan was even more complicated and
we sort of stepped on it uh we stepped
in on it because
um this was the first
configuration and you don't know are
these three Courtyards or is that a
public space and the courtyard we opened
it because that didn't make sense to
make a public space so it's it's a
Passage through the block two Courtyards
then we had to respect this existing
building because people wanted to stay
here so we had to open up this and uh so
with this morphological transformation
we ended up here in in the end we we
pushed down the part towards the South
and towards the nice view on the water
uh in the back we have nine floors or 10
floors and in the front we have only
three floors this is how it happened and
now if you go to Hamburg halfen City
everywhere you have that you have these
shapes but these building don't even
have
roofs yeah pot
plot uh the diimler
building and of course Without You
Ferris uh and uh without REM bringing up
this uh example of you Ferris uh
probably we wouldn't have been able to
make that
building but it's very similar to those
Pont wall front wall buildings and uh
this the sculptural quality of those was
similarly uh influential to the project
and at that time we had already
developed uh the relief which is on the
lower floors horizontal then it's more
or less balanced and of course on the
top where you have to define the ground
and where you have to make a
skyscraper uh which uh talks more to the
sky than to the ground as CES Cesar P
said uh you you have to the the
verticals take
over it's all made from uh prefab
elements and of course you the the the
task is to make the joints
disappear you don't see the joints
because they are hidden on the
side and
uh I I was sitting several days once in
the inter quanti which is where the
photograph has been made and looking at
this miracle when the sun uh comes up in
the morning until it goes down in the
evening how this situation in Chicago is
transformed it's simply
breathtaking and here how this
skyscraper type after the fire in
Chicago developed from six stories seven
stories it goes up it's parcellation the
ground level is important and then at a
certain point it becomes important what
happens at the
corners and like the bow Academy of
shinkle and he probably was rather
influential for the Chicago architecture
of the after the grand fire uh yeah here
already because he didn't think about
highrises but he was experienced in
building
Gothic architecture he for him there was
no contradiction between Gothic tectonic
and classical tectonic that's why it was
easy for him to let the
pilasters uh push through the
corners and this is one of his
paintings
so fascination of the gothic and I have
not been here in Yale since 20 20 years
and and now for me the gothic or the
gothic that has
built not even 100 years ago 80 70 years
ago in the 30s 70 80 years ago yeah it's
absolutely uh
astonishing and uh of course with the CL
with the classical uh principle you end
up with the law with the laws called
so you have to do this step and the
European architects who made highrises
didn't do that step why didn't they do
this step because uh
the uh the gothic uh tectonic to them
was not
uh uh did not lend itself uh for
practical translation because they
somehow were reluctant to take the uh
Church image and turn it into uh a uh
normal uh uh uh building office
building uh here
the Tower of the Woolworth
Building and uh the uh Tower of the
cathedral in
Strasburg
and that's why there are no no real
skyscrapers in Europe you know they were
completely
blocked
now um for what you have seen here and
for uh for my
uh education as an
architect there were
several um experiences in important from
the Cornell time one of them was John W
reps uh making of urban America because
for
Europeans the cities the old cities
Berlin is a rather is an exception is a
very young City but the old cities they
go back uh you cannot trace it back to
the to the first to the first step the
American cities you go uh not even 200
years back and there is somebody and who
comes across with his family and makes a
makes a building and this is the
beginning of making a city so that gave
me a completely new idea of what a city
is and here you have the New Haven plan
uh with the uh
green and uh it took I think it took 200
years somehow to uh to really Define
this square but the the settlers came
over and said we keep this 300 by 300
met or something we keep it open for
public function for public
representation and take Savannah
Georgia until until the middle of the
last century uh they extended the city
according to this
grid and sometimes it just didn't
succeed uh another influence was
certainly Colin row and his colar
City and uh um just as an example for
this influence the he competition we won
for the Ministries uh of uh justice and
interior
here a project by uh Leon K's
brother and uh yeah
something which is like a Colin row
configuration for us it was important
since these towers uh became rather big
even though they are 160 m or so High um
and
to here is the the government and the
the historic
Center and the view from there was the
major aspect of uh cutting the towers
into uh two elements with steep angles
to let
them appear more
elegantly and here again the the
Dutch single
houses six story seven story
and
then it can can go higher there is no
limit yeah it and the decision of the he
government in that small Old City uh uh
making the seat for the
Ministries um
that for us is Possible only if we take
the uh structure of the city the volume
uh of the city and from there project
the towers uh into the
sky a one Tower in almost white granite
and the other in in h red
brick here you see quite nicely the the
scale of these small houses and it how
it relates in material but also in the
tectonic uh quality uh to the historic
buildings and
um also this book was important for us
but uh uh as intriguing as these
pictures
were
um our and our building at pot plat has
even has a certain similarity to this
building on a
triangular uh floor uh plan uh it rather
than projecting an idea into the city we
try to let this idea uh being being born
so to so to say from from inside the
conditions of the site the program the
client and so
on and it's a completely different
approach than uh this one uh uh it's not
uh the attempt to make inventions and uh
insert them into the city but rather let
uh the building be itself uh out of the
conditions which you
find so uh it's different from um uh the
mass production which needs to be
designed
in a fashion uh that uh is intriguing
for the consumer and uh here
I
um uh have to make some comments to our
Uh current uh situation as Architects
and urban uh
designers um I feel that uh we are
together
uh walking into a crisis of mass
production and at the same time of our
uh democracy which became or is becoming
these days one and the same thing it's
exchangeable our type of democracy and
our kind of
consumerism and U I believe there are
simply things which are not question of
uh
consumption and uh um there was one
person uh
who
probably can give us an idea of what is
happening there and where we
stand uh who visited the
states
um almost 200 years ago uh his name was
to
and he came to America in
1831 and uh uh when he arrived in New
York at the uh East and passed by the
East
River uh he was totally fascinated by
those white temples there were uh he
recognized here a whole number of white
uh
temples and uh the the next day
he um uh came there and and and found
out that these temples were not made in
Marble uh but in wood and they were not
temples they were simple houses and he
was incredibly
disappointed because they were were made
in wood and uh uh for us that that is
not a problem because we know that you
can uh exchange wood for stone and back
again um but uh he his reflection goes
further and uh he says in aristocratic
societies each Artisan should produce
the best possible uh product and the
best possible uh
workmanship and uh
um in this new Democratic Society he saw
coming up um since there were no no uh
uh
professional um entities anymore
everybody could open uh his shop uh he
said uh um everybody is gaining the
greatest possible quantity of money
money at the last possible cost this
would be the uh principle of this uh
democracy
democracy um which he saw coming up in
America um and uh the will of the
customer he said is then the only
limit uh but the customer turned into
the consumer and also changed
um and this consumer did not have um any
sense anymore uh about what is wellmade
and longlasting or not and uh he said in
in in this in this time in the early
times uh the even uh simple uh people
would prefer rather to refrain from
buying an uh object of uh
imperfection
um the
Craftsman
work um in AR
aristocracies only for a limited
number three three minutes only for a
limited number uh of uh
customers uh who are rather
fastidious The Profit they hope to make
depends principally on the Perfection of
the
workmanship such is no longer the case
when all privileges being abolished says
to ranks
are intermingled and Men Are Forever
rising and and men are and since men are
in this Society
rising and sinking upon the letter of
society in democracies there are always
a multitude of
individuals uh whose wants are above
their means and who are very willing to
take up with imperfect satisfaction
rather than abandon the object of their
desires the Workman then strives to
invent methods which may enable him not
only to work better but quicker and
cheaper or if he cannot succeed in that
to diminish the intrinsic qualities of
the thing he
makes and uh in the
end they would strive to give to all
their Commodities attractive qualities
which they do not in reality
process today I think we would call this
design design is what you can do if you
can't do things well says the German
philosopher slauter dke thank you very
[Applause]
much
sorry no I don't need I have
it
um I think I've made a terrible
mistake
because while I think the title missed
opportunities is slightly self-
congratulatory I first have to applaud
Hans kolhoff for not falling victim uh
to such a title uh as you will see I
have
um I'm going to talk about uh my missed
opportunities um in Berlin I also feel
that I made a mistake because uh hearing
the last presentation this morning uh I
believe that it would have been far
better to been in um this panel missed
opportunities uh although you all can
say well it's not 2020 yet from what I
saw this morning uh I believe it would
qualify for this panel uh and uh having
been concerned about being in the last
EA I want to suggest that uh Victorio
lampani who was one of my Guides Through
that time uh all my complaints about
that all of my complaints about earlier
talks Mr Creer Etc uh go out the window
uh when I see what's going to happen
2020 in Berlin probably some of us will
still not be around uh and that's
probably a good thing uh
um I um want to begin my talk by
arriving in London in
1960 and there was a
Prohibition uh at that time for building
uh tall buildings and uh I thought what
a quaint idea that was at the time uh I
thought London was a fabulous City
I now go back to London where
they're
literally Tower upon Tower uh done by
some of the world's best
Architects uh I think including our own
RAM kulas and I think that was a good
idea uh because uh I think you know you
can't keep things the way they were and
so I'm going to show you two towers that
when I first proposed them in the 1990s
in Berlin there was a bit of a
Prohibition uh about uh tall buildings
um it might have been the nature of my
tall buildings and not perfectly
prepared to believe that uh but uh again
um I will leave that for other
commentators uh to digress upon
um
I have participated in five unrealized
projects in Berlin more than any other
city in the world uh where I have been
working so there I have a very fondness
for Berlin because I really like
unrealized projects I'm better off with
unrealized projects uh perhaps than
realized ones um in any case to keep the
thing short because I made a short talk
uh um knowing that uh we would be short
of time uh uh I will proceed the first
project uh that I'm going to speak about
is the max Reinhardt house um which was
uh projected in
1992 it was a project that was
commissioned by the Reinhardt family on
the site of their the former
uh uh famous uh Shia house by uh four
reinhard's theater uh by I believe it
was Pig but I could be wrong uh was
right yeah I keep thinking is it Max to
is it but it's it was pulsy in any case
um it was a site that was in the middle
of nowhere I mean not on a Major Street
set back Etc and reinhardt's wanted to
have a foundation and a and a multi-use
building uh which a developer was
willing uh at the time to uh finance and
um there is the uh site plan um and the
model let's see so I don't point this at
anybody wrongly uh the spray River the
uh the bonhof uh here uh and uh we are
that's the friederich stasa bridge and
here is where the old Pig theater was
and there was the tower what we were
doing at the time um it's not quite not
too tall by the way uh we were doing
something it was one of the first
projects that dealt with um what
was very important in
1992 uh the ideas of gender
specificity and uh it was an attempt to
suggest that a tower could be non
phallocentric uh which is a word uh was
very important at the time half of this
audience will not know what that word
means and it's not important uh but uh
phago centrism was was a real hot issue
right and uh so maybe uh the the the
idea was uh to see if we could build a
tower that had no inside no
outside um but was what we knew at the
time was a mbia strip um all of these
drawings uh in in in one sense are pre
uh the fabulous algorithms that we have
today for generating such things we had
a platform called form Z which only
could facet uh and instead of giving you
figures it could give you planes and the
reason why this is a planer uh shape is
because um that was the only thing we
could use um there were actually plans
worked out for this Tower uh part of it
being the the uh Reinhardt uh
uh song and part of it was uh rental
properties and part of it a hotel so it
was a a multi-use uh project
um and uh there you can see the the
section uh the computer
generated um uh model and uh the actual
project itself um which importantly went
down into the ground in other words
completed itself uh
underground um there you can see these
faceted
shapes that uh the computer gave us but
it was an idea that what was inside
could be outside and vice versa in other
words it it uh Twisted through itself so
in a continuous loop so there was both
both outside and inside were one and the
same thing um another series of uh
models
um did it fit into its surroundings
no
uh was it intended to no uh it was
supposed to be an ion to the Reinhardt
memory Etc and had that quality of the
theater that
Reinhardt uh uh was so important in
developing in
Berlin and here is a model later made
for an
exhibition uh in at the M uh where you
can see the complete uh version in a um
glass uh plastic enclosed ground uh
showing the the the
project we then um and for whatever
reasons um we didn't build that project
uh the Reinhardt family is still after
me uh wanting to build it um I was
hoping for a ground swell of excitement
uh from this audience and we'd sign a
petition Occupy Wall Street and
uh they're they're talking about
building it on Governor's Island I'm
certain that that's not where it should
be
um uh in any case another developer came
along and said we have another site that
you would be interested in the site of
me's uh 1922 glass uh Skyscraper the
spray dry a site and um we'd like you to
um
try a tower uh this uh Tower was one of
the first uh that uh very smooth uh and
the clearly the computer programs by 98
and 99 had changed uh so that we had a
much more control over uh the the kind
of project that we wanted it's one of uh
the really uh
Sleek uh versions of that you begin to
see now
uh popping up all over the world uh this
was in
1998 much before most of them began it
it was a an amalgam from uh the two
towers that me did there were two
versions of the tower um the one on the
left and the one on the right clearly uh
of different uh vintages but uh similar
ideas what we did
was to take uh the me uh the the
Triangular me Tower uh which was here
and all our computer could do at the
time uh was to U morph it and we morphed
from here and morphing was part of what
computer processes do now without even
telling you uh to produce uh this
project here and here was the uh typical
flooor plan um and um we figured out
with the developer and the engineers
that uh we would be adding 20% to the
cost of the skin only which was
15% of the building so we were adding a
fraction of the cost uh of the project
um I find uh the the picture here
uh quite engaging um when we think of
some of the recent uh downtown uh
skycrapers uh that follow similar lines
um again um we were uh asked to uh move
some other
place uh I I I don't call it a Miss
opportunity mind you but uh there you
are so um those are the uh two projects
that uh I wanted to show um they I will
not show the five other unrealized
projects because uh I want to give time
uh to our guests uh so that we uh are
able to hear everybody thank you very
much
I'm here today I think because of two
things also I took literature classes
with Peter Eisman at Cooper Union on
poststructuralist literature and I won a
competition where hun kof was the jury
president in um but only because he had
to leave the last day when the jury
making was done I guess so um this is a
good point to start this presentation
which um gives a little bit of a private
history to somebody who came to Berlin
in
'94 um not being involved really in the
moment when the wall fell and uh not
really involved in these early
discussions on how Berlin should be like
and what is the vision for the
city I came in '94 in a moment where
there wasn't intense Dynamic
transformation um mostly in the Arts in
music in theater in literature it didn't
really happen in architecture which was
more a discussion or discourse fueled by
a sentiment of loss rather than a
curiosity of the new or for the new
there was a vision as we experienced in
my generation uh a vision of
uniformity um versus trying to
understand what the multiplicity can be
of a contemporary Society
where are the unique potentials of
Berlin to rebuild a contemporary City
based on its complex
pasts but it also gave us the great
opportunity to look at the world outside
to work outside of Berlin with that
experience with these discussions we
experienced in the city to see the
potentials of Berlin maybe applied
somewhere
else so Berlin became the hotbed of um a
cultural reference for the work in our
office it became somehow um an
understanding of an architecture as a
catalyst as an activator and we used
architecture as a writing but which
story uh story to
tell the primordial soup for our work
came kind of uh by chance it's a letter
soup that I would not call data
protection pattern and these patterns
are found in around 1994 when I moved to
Berlin they were invented and produced
maybe in the late 19th century but
around 19113 100 years ago um basically
a very crucial year as also Florian
illis just describes and documents in
his book 1913 which is the best seller
in Germany right now um became also uh
crucial because the largest fund
developer and print developer for letter
sets and um types uh and funds was based
in Berlin it is a company called bold
which went bankrupt in the 80s um placed
in Maring Dam in Berlin and they were
crucial for what we know today as
writing and printing and media basically
one of the very early developers of
media um
production what we have uh here with the
data protection patterns is a strategic
tool a contemporary ornament um that
deals very clearly with ideas of privacy
or private information and public
exposure it comes when you get PIN
numbers from your bank or your salary
slips it protects the personal
information from a kind of uh
non-controlled View and these patterns
somehow became a prototype for our work
as a metaph for how we deal in a culture
of data obsessed um obsessed economy it
is something where we can learn about
about how issues of inside and outside
private and public um discret indiscret
hidden exposed are constantly negotiated
along this fine membrane um that also
can be seen as a kind of a prototype or
metaphor for
architecture it is a tool to reflect
that spatial implications that we now as
Architects have to think about um how
architecture is produced in a culture
that deals with these issues so we take
these patterns as a starting point to
explore what are um the spaces we want
to deal with there are samples um that
show the kind of the transport the
transformation from uh two-dimensional
stategic element to a spatial entity
from small scale two Dimensions to
threedimensional and urban scale and I'm
showing you here some of the examples um
the patterns that I collected in the
last 20 years you see that them as
numbers as letters this is the beral a
in Maring Dam um where basically all
these types were produced and in their
catalog from 1913 they offer these Le
stems with the patterns
already so this is what you see and this
is actually the letters here this letter
soup this primordial soup um that is
kind of the background um for our work
and here are the examples of envelopes
that you get every day in your mail it's
somehow maybe the last visible system of
control of these issues of private and
public or personal and um uh available
to everybody where once you understand
what the Technologies and the strategics
um are you can also understand how they
happen now in the digital virtual
invisible World um around
us these are examples where you see the
numbers and letters and it comes as you
know points um maray effects camouflage
patterns um you'll see them every day in
your mail as I said before they come as
logos um it's a whole universe a graphic
universe that
um helps us to understand and explore um
our spatial
ideas I'm showing now step by step how
we translate these patterns into a
larger kind of spatial idea where it
becomes human scale where we can inhabit
them where we start to get get immerged
into immersed into these patterns uh
this is an installation we did in Berlin
at the Berlin Gallery it's a carpet
installation where it wraps and
envelopes the building um and gives you
somehow first one toone relationship
they become also step by step thre
dimensionalized and the cubes that you
see here um on the pedestals are maybe
the most kind of uh explicit translation
of these patterns from 2D to 3D when you
see on the upper left a pattern as it is
printed two dimensionally you can read
the five and the seven and the nine and
so forth as soon as you turn around it
becomes a spatial complicated Labyrinth
and complexity there's a
three-dimensional interpretation of
these patterns into a different form of
spatial experience and step by step I'm
showing examples how that translates
into a larger um architecture this is
for the outer stud in wolburg an
exhibition design or a dining hall in
curer um which was built earlier but you
also see this kind of structure of the
skeletons becoming the space defining
elements or even larger at Courthouse we
are finishing right now it should be
opened in April in hustled in Belgium on
the new uh site along the train
tracks or the relief idea um and the
preparations of facades in this uh
office building in
Hamburg issues of trigger and ground
also here in a villa near ludik Borg in
uh Southern in
Germany and one building we built so far
in Berlin which is this housing on
johanes stza facing the uh Tales area in
the center of Berlin here you see a
glass building because it's a very
narrow Street at some point um where
issues of privacy and intimacy was
crucial in our understanding this is the
site it's a front house in a side Wing a
very typical layout um of a Berlin
building and we wanted to take the green
quality of the courtyards into the
building stepping up uh the green and
the on Terraces um all the way up um
into the top floors you see it also in
the section as this landscape um
understanding landscape living that we
might have taken over from the 70s back
into a building of
today but it's the floor plan that
indicated or guided us to the facade
where you see here um the front house
was looking into the apartments of the
side wi and of course there needed to be
some areas where you create privacy um
and of course also openness so this map
of degrees of discretion as we call them
gave us an understanding how certain
ideas of privacy can be created in a
building which is mostly a glass
building to get a lot of light into it
this is the view from the front house
along the side wi um at some point it's
swapped over also to the front facade
because we kind of like the facad a lot
and it also would make sense on the
street facade because it's a very narrow
Street where there's a lot of kind of
close um adjacency from the other
buildings as
well some close-ups of this facade um
this is the entrance that guides you and
it's kind of this curtain uh kind of a
new curtain wall uh that seduces uh you
to enter the building and this is again
A View From the backyard
and the main
facade this we translate now into a
larger project it's a highrise in dorf
which just won um a half a year ago and
we are now in the design development
phase and another high-rise for dorf um
it somehow became a site a city that
likes us um this is a town uh Town
Center of complex with a 100 m highrise
um hopefully starting in about 2 years
it's still going through the zone
phase ideas of transformation are
important with our architecture and that
helps us to reflect and look back at the
context where we work in and maybe what
we learned from Berlin is that if
there's a situation that came from a
very kind of precise regime and there's
a shift of Paradigm um then also needs
to be an architecture that kind of
guides a vision for the future we were
invited by the georgean government to be
part part of a translation or
transformation of an earlier regime
towards a new contemporary country and
all the dots that you see are buildings
we are involved with so maybe actually
Georgia is the largest project we work
on right now um I want to show you some
of these kind of acupunctural um
interventions into the country that all
are um let's say key points
infrastructural key points um where you
would you might experience the city the
country for the first time or actually
when you Transit through the country
that's what you might see maybe it's the
only thing that you see in terms of
architecture we built a checkpoint it's
a Border Station between Georgia and
turkey on the Black Sea Coast which you
see here and the Fantastic understanding
um of the government I thought was that
it wasn't meant to be a separation line
it wasn't meant to be a declaration
here's where my country ends and this is
where your country starts or where your
country ends it's meant to be a meeting
Point rather than a a kind of a
separation border we have um conference
rooms there are Terraces to overlook the
Black Sea actually people can go quite
close and also you know use it based
there um it's kind of a public space if
you like and which other country can you
imagine that sees a building like this
as part of an opening process rather
than a separation control system some
images how you would experience it how
this country says hello to you or
goodbye on the other hand
um here you see a section with the
conference rooms and The Terraces
overlooking the Black Sea that you can
rent and of course it works Night and
Day and
Night another project is a very small
airport in mestia which is all the way
up in the Caucasian Mountains um it's
developed into a tourism Resort um
beautiful uh ski resort which has to be
developed but of course is in a very
kind of old um historical cultural
setting which is mestia that you see in
uh in the background it has all these
Old Stone Towers um that make kind of
the landmark of uh this
site and the Tower of course references
partly these proportions of the old
Towers but also introduces a new
infrastructure which is the small
airport that's maybe the only way you
can get there really or you drive 10
hours by car up the street into the
mountains another project in the same
city is a small town hall that we've
just finished and also a police station
um in the very center of the
city two other projects in gory are rest
stops along the new highway and the
highway is also the first Highway
they're building right now to run from
east to west uh Georgia is a Transit
country um also with other you know
agricultural qualities and and economic
forces but the transit is a key point in
the economy there and so it's also
important to understand that the rest
stops are not only kind of service
stations along the highway but they also
are activators um in their locality um
they would be built sometimes in areas
where there is no highway yet but they
would bring a supermarket they would
bring a cultural room where they can
show arts and crafts that would provide
a roof for local farmers market Etc so
they really work as kind of um first
indicators of a change of the country
and uh when we were there for the
opening I think the biggest honor was
that here in gory um that's actually the
town where Stalin was born um people
already applied for having their festiv
uh their festivities after their wedding
ceremony in the restop so you can
imagine the urge for something new and
some kind of other forms of spaces for
um the population there and the last one
I want to show you from Georgia is in
lasika lasika is an
urban planning scheme for a new town for
500,000 people on the Black Sea Coast
from scratch basically um here you see
what's happened so far it's a Boulevard
it's a small um Town Hall in the end and
appear with a structure a sculpture that
we just finish or is actually going to
be finished in the next couple of weeks
it's a splash kind of a frozen splash in
the sea um that kind of indicates is a
marker for this new development to come
and here you see how we translated this
into an object that is an identifier for
um this new development to come just
some pictures from the construction
phase um and this is a photo we just got
two weeks ago from um the local
construction
people we might see if it really works
as an indicator for a new city because
the new uh elected government gave up
the idea of building a new town there so
it might just sit there and thrust
along um what happens otherwise with
structures like this in a very dense
populated part is our project in ceville
and this is maybe what we learned also
from um our Berlin experience that there
is a desire to really use public space
and open airspace as something to
experience a communal um discourse a
communal feel and uh in a way civil had
a similar problem that of course you
know people are on the street in Spain
all the time and the weather and the
atmosphere helps you more than the
Berlin grainless um six month of the
year but here it also was an area in the
city which was a little bit um forgotten
it's although very Central it's the very
center of the medieval Town Center um
but it was kind of given up a couple of
years
ago which I'll show you in a second here
you see some AAL views of Metropol
parasol in the very
Center another view
closer and it was important in the
competition that we won in
2004 that the site somehow becomes
reevaluated as a new heart for the city
of ceville it sits in the very center as
I mentioned before it was a hole for the
last 30 years it was kind of a non-place
for the last 30 years and the
competition asked to find a way to keep
this window into the history of civil
which are Roman ruins and found you know
Moses and so forth to introduce the
market again which was there before but
also think about what is kind of an
urban space in the 21st century this was
the market in the um in the 50 until the
50s and 70s which was then taken down um
this is how it looked like it was really
run down and became dangerous I think
nowadays we would try to save it but in
the' 70s the car was more important um
to introduce to the city
and this was the parking lot for about
20 to 30
years when we worked on the competition
I had a couple of ideas in mind how a a
kind of a public space would work not as
a frame as you would have it in Plaza
mayor or plazs but with objects
activated as magnets or with magnets um
that are certain institutions and plad
Incarnation was always an institution it
was never really a square there was a
cler before it got bigger the Closter
got bigger um they ripped out more
fabric then it became the market and
then when the market was taken down we
felt that we also had to introduce again
some kind of object that is the center
of or is the main point of this public
space so we looked at some examples and
I live very close to the gnis C here and
I really like it as this extremely
beautiful Ensemble um kind of a set of
objects which constantly attracts
different forms of activities then it's
empty again then there's something else
happening so it's a a fluctuation a
pulse that the city um kind of needs and
the city celebrates and sometimes it's
really ugly like you know they have
these ice skate rings and these jumping
air I don't know castles and then it's a
really beautiful moment where you have
maybe a Christmas Market or even um kind
of a street performance um happening
there similar also the square in cow
where you have the Market Hall in the
center and this Tower and they become
kind of these accumulators um
of uh different activities and
performances on the street and even this
Plaza here in Mexico City with this huge
flag um has a certain programmatic idea
where you sit there or stand there when
you have to wait um and escape the
sun Metropol parasol also is all about
Shadow it's about creating a climate
where you can um enjoy the outside uh in
a city that's a lot um heated uh during
the year and Shadow also as a kind of a
design tool or as a as an animator of
the space was important so this is at
one point of the day and then it looks
completely different at some other time
of the day when you look at it from the
sky this is a ping map you hardly see it
um it becomes somehow
invisible and there are some sketches
how we developed it so the roof was
really The Guiding point and then we had
to bring down the loads at very selected
Parts into the foundations to really um
make it allow it actually even to be
built because there were some protected
parts we couldn't um
touch and we tested some different
programs the cloud or this kind of
mushroom structure was always there and
we also tried to find out why is this
working so well um we haven't really
been there for the competition it was an
uh kind of anonymous competition in the
first phase
and then they selected 10 projects and
then we had to all present to each other
and um be kind of in a dialogue also
with the public but in the first phase
it was more of a remote um uh kind of
intervention but then in the second
phase we were going back and looked at
why it made so much sense and so he here
you see trees from a neighboring Plaza
very similar in the sculptural quality
this is a beautiful stone roof of the
cathedral this kind of undulated flying
carpet of stone which was another
reference and of course the inside of um
the gothic Cathedral the structure that
becomes the space defining element the
layers are archaeology Museum Food
Market elevated Plaza and then the roof
to create Shadow with a restaurant and a
Skywalk the design process somehow
worked the other way around from top to
bottom but it shows that there is an
idea of a public space that more than
just you know an untouched public space
it's a different uh kind of combination
of programs not unpr problematic in
terms of public and private um
partnership as this project was
developed um but it gives you different
pockets of activities in different kind
of neighborhoods to the square which are
all important in its daily life here's
some view from the archaeology Museum
these are the sections um it's about 100
meter long 180 M long 75 M wide and 30 m
high it was all built in in a Timber
construction which um we kind of
developed a new from the dining hall I
showed you earlier this green kind of
skeleton structure but it's not really
important in terms of how it works now
in dialogue with the city and I think in
this dialogue between the existing old
fabric of civil and this um new
sculptural um space celebrated by the
citizens really makes the quality um of
this
project
for
there was of course criticism um mostly
from the Catholic religious conservative
group of um civilians but last year kind
of the year after it opened this was the
cover of the zanana Santa which is the
religious week before Easter um where
they have all the program and the kind
of the activities described and it
appeared to be on the covers so maybe
there's also some shift of understanding
and appreciation of this project in
their everyday kind of ritual or annual
ritual of the city you see it here the
city shuts down they have these
processions there's a different kind of
music in the city there's kind of this
breath of people carrying these really
heavy structures um there's a
celebration of a different kind of uh
history of the city but there's also of
course a website and the Facebook page
so it's managed well you know which
needs to be done it appeared already in
a couple of music videos this is a very
cheesy Latino pop it also works for
hip-hop
supposedly um and another cheesy one is
in the
elevator it also worked well for the
Euro games last year this is um I think
one of the Final gamees Shots where the
people really choose that place as the
place to celebrate the country or their
soccer
players it also was soci for a action
movie this is a shooting that happened
on Plaza Incarnation and it was the
celebration point for Gay Pride or the
cartoon Festival um so you see
transformations of this project already
happen into different forms of creative
response and it was also the site for
revolution The indignados Who choose
Metropol parasol as their site to
discuss about the future of their
society of the future of Spain of the
future um of their City and again it
really works for all kinds of different
Appropriations different discussions
about the future of our
society so our work not really is about
answers it's about trying to find out if
our projects can open up questions um
about what could should or would be a
possible future for our cities and this
project I think is one that poses that
question quite well thank you very much
[Applause]
R are you
there we get REM
in I see
him can we make him a bit
bigger
okay can
you say something we make sure we hear
you uh do you want me to say something
we would love you to we would love you
to respond to these three presentations
hi hi uh well I think it would need a
mind more elastic than mine to can
really respond to these three um
presentations uh I really can't uh maybe
the only thing I can do is to kind of
really address uh slightly the issue of
capital city missed
opportunity um and I made some kind of
very short points and that I will
communicate it and that will be it I
think that very few people in America
now can imagine the incredible aura that
Berlin built uh over the 20th
century um kind of first
by inventing modernity then by inventing
enormity then of course uh through the
war accumulating enormous guilt and then
uh in the form of the wall uh to create
an exceptional uniqueness that no other
city has ever
achieved and uh although the aura was
maybe a negative Aura I think it was
nevertheless very strong and perhaps the
can Real Genius of ERS is to really see
that aura and to take it in his hands
and to declare Berlin kind of
laboratory and that is uh really in in
that sense uh kind of stroke of Genius
that uh established Berlin as a kind of
very unique situation now if you look at
190 uh
1989 the Wall fell and I think that in a
certain way you have to kind of read the
fall of the wall as the beginning of uh
Berlin's U loss of
Aura uh it lost its uniqueness um
because it was became a city almost like
any
other but I think very few people in
America right now can imagine is the
extent to which 89 was kind of almost a
panic
uh it really was as if America would
discover that the Midwest in its
entirety had been stuck into the 19th
century and as if America would decide
that it would undo have to undo that
inequality uh in less than 10 years the
the sheer effort of the re unification
is kind of really in in current
political uh president almost most
unimaginable and it is no uh surprise in
a way that uh Berlin had kind of very
little opportunity to within that Panic
also to seriously consider or to
carefully consider uh what the status of
uh Capital would mean for
Berlin um you will later hear a
presentation by
stimon uh uh he has an interesting name
it means voiceman uh he is very
convinced uh it was he who kind created
the um image of the capital Berlin uh
and and who adopted a model or imposed a
model of uh the ideal uh historical
city um and I think that what he didn't
realize and what very you realized is
that there was a kind of coincidence
between the ideal increment of his ideal
city and the ideal increment of the
market economy which of course by 89 uh
the end of teter's reain and the uh end
of Reagan's Reign was at its most
intense so I think that the best and the
most counterproductive way of looking at
perhaps this whole situation
is not to uh keep beoning kind of lost
opportunities or
to uh uh think that uh there was a
theoretical bin that could have existed
and that would have been kind of
infinitely more uh kind of rich and and
unusual than the current one I think uh
what has been uh almost inevitable uh
partly through the distraction and
partly through the kind of historical
forces of the market economy is that
kind of Berlin Berlin uh ultimately lost
its Aura and became a city like uh any
other and I think that is the kind of
story that uh uh we have been hearing
without perhaps making it explicit and
that you will be hearing in the future
thank
[Applause]
you sleep
now 9:00 yes to get his dressed early uh
uh shall we have a little conversation
among our um participants oh it's late
Peter is saying it's late and
he and we have to have another panel
okay so if we can have the
lights uh and uh maybe we need uh do we
need a break or can we go right into
it five minute break uh bio
break uh we will
resume at a quarter of
four
I